what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for an interview that I'm very
excited about right now because I can't
believe I'm saying this we're
celebrating the 10th anniversary of The
Purge with uh The Purge franchise
Creator James demonico how is it 10
years already
I don't know it doesn't make any sense
to me either I vividly remember seeing
that movie in the Angelica of all places
very first time yeah the irony of that
is that we just you know I never thought
it would play in any Multiplex across
the country when I wrote it because I
came up with the ad 20 years the movies
the idea this franchise is 10 years old
but the idea of the movie is 20 years
old and when it was conceived we thought
it would just play with Angelica that
was it we thought it'll be this tiny
indie horror Thriller and I didn't think
it had any mainstream appeal we had over
80 I think we counted 80 passes because
the script was so um anti-American so we
just assumed if we do get it made it's
going to play in a very small venue like
the Angelica which is my favorite
theater when I went to NYU when
so yeah so you're seeing it there is
kind of oddly ironic in the word way now
because I'm curious has anyone who
passed on the original script like have
you reconnected with anyone and gotten
their thoughts on the growth of the
franchise yeah I spoke to the one person
years ago my producer actually spoke to
Luke bassan that passed because he
financed my first film
and uh Lucas expressed some regret that
his people I don't know if he says he
saw orders people passed on it but we
must we sent it to Luke first because he
had fined that Staten Island New York
which I directed in uh 2007. so yeah his
pass I think was the one we heard I
think a couple other companies might
have said something I can't remember now
so many that it was uh it was just
everybody was passing until Blum until
Jason saw something that was what
changed the kind of trajectory knows a
thing or two about us
a franchise exactly exactly so you wrote
the script quite a long time ago at this
point but I am curious if you remember
this what would you say is the biggest
difference between draft one of the
screenplay and what we now have in the
final film oh absolutely uh I think
draft one would have been x-rated
because of its violence
so my produce my my producing partner
Sebastian Mercier who produced along
with Jason uh
before I show anyone what I write I go
through Sebastian's intense uh process
and so he brought it down to violence I
was really trying to do this discourse
on violence and it was a big metaphor
for gun lack of gun control laws in
America so I was pushing the envelope
deeply uh so with that got taken down
and the Ethan character the Ethan Hawke
James Sandman character was he was an
actual he didn't just sell security
systems because I wanted to be a
morality play he actually
this is the big thing that we call we
put it in part two a little bit
um he he purged someone in the basement
as a ritual every year he bought someone
and to purge his own as you know the
societal catharsis that The Purge has
promised to be that'll make you a better
person he bought fully into this
propaganda and uh kills a man on page 25
that's the first Purge of the movie and
that's probably the only real note that
we got from Universal was they thought
that was the Compromise it was kind of
they thought the story The morality play
was in the DNA of the piece without
having seen Ethan's character James sand
and kill a man you know the fact that he
sold security systems they thought that
he was making a profit off The Purge was
enough to show the economic benefit to
his family and that he was uh buying
into the propaganda of the holiday so
that went that was the big cut that
affected uh so yeah and we put it in
part two we kind of saw that where they
buy uh uh there's a there's a man who
gets bored it's Harmony Joe Go's um Dad
gets bought by a rich family very
similar to what we had in first one okay
I'm gonna go back to the the extreme
violence that you cut back on because on
the one hand it's not being able to do
something you originally wanted to do
but by pulling back on the violence is
there any I don't know is that is there
any stronger story element that you
discovered by not having the film be as
gore-heavy as you originally intended I
think it was more of a Vibe I think
having the audience imagine what's
actually happening out there I think
it's sometimes more than we can do we
were so limited on budget so it was a
lot of stuff but we're not even gonna be
able to do that
and so I think what we learned was that
the audience's imagination would fill in
the blanks and that was a great just
lesson for me even as a writer more than
even as a director was
sometimes I think especially in the
horror genre letting the audience fill
in the gaps could be more even scarier
than what we perceive as let's show it
all and I tried to learn that lesson
even in my newest film I've tried to say
okay
uh less might be more
and I think that was a great lesson
would you want to show it all as a
filmmaker now let's shoot this let's
shoot that let's put it all in there
we'll edit it out later if we don't need
it but you know when you have such
budgetary constraints it forces you to
work within a box and say okay what's
important to tell the story so I think
yeah I think it just less is more was
the big lesson there if that's a boring
answer but it's one of the most
disturbing parts of all of my favorite
horror movies is how my mind will spin
out of control more so than if I were to
be overtly shown the most terrific thing
in the world exactly and I think that
goes to various things uh
not just Gore but even story points let
things we don't have to tell everything
I think sometimes the writer in me wants
to say okay let's explain it all
and I'm reading this amazing novel Now
by uh I forgot the writer's name who
wrote eyes watch shut it's his
experience of our writing Eyes Wide Shut
with Kubrick and all Kubrick keeps
telling him in every draft that comes in
is just take it all out we don't have to
explain anything it's a fascinating
thing it's a fascinating thing I think
because you get very worried that the
audience is going to misunderstand some
some thought you had in your head that
you they want to spell out so I think
as I get older I'm learning that the
audience is way smarter than my worries
are so that makes sense with that in
mind is there any reaction to the first
Purge movie that
surprised you whether it was like a like
a plot detail that folks filled in on
their own or maybe maybe something
people had a really big reaction to that
you didn't think would spark such a big
response I think the biggest thing over
the all the course of all the purge
films is that there are there's a
portion of the audience I don't think
it's big I pray it's not big that
doesn't see that I'm telling this
morality play that The Purge is a very
bad thing and that's where it gets very
strange some people see it as this odd
wish fulfillment you know we have as you
know we do all these massive test
screenings you know we do 300 people we
test these movie three times so we're
looking at 900 written responses from
the audience and there is a portion of
the audience that loved loves the idea
of purging and it's very scary I wrote
it as this horror you know I hate guns
so I wrote it to me the scariest day in
America could be a day where people
legally could use guns and um so that
was truly
and there was a big portion of the
audience so this was scary too I guess
who said they would have never I kind of
get this I on some level I understand
protecting your family but a lot of
people were like there's no way when the
young boy lets the homeless stranger
into the home who was in jeopardy
I'd say half of that first test
screening was like
I would never no one would ever do no
one would ever do not just a little boy
but no one would ever let someone in on
that night
and I got their argument but I'm like
he's a little boy and he's calling this
complex moral structure of The Purge and
what does it mean and he sees a man
struggling and screaming he doesn't know
maybe it's a ruse maybe it's somebody
he's not thinking this way he's just
seeing a man in trouble but there was an
audience a lot of the audience was like
no way no way anyone lets them in so we
we've got battled with those things yeah
I remember that discourse quite vividly
and also just you know the initial
reaction to a new high concept like this
being like well what would you do on
Purge Night which you know does kind of
defeat the purpose the whole franchise
exactly exactly what would you do I
would say go to Canada but that is the
big question I get all the time so it
does not surprise me to hear that sadly
um going back to the big set pieces we
actually do see in the final film 10
years later now looking back is there
any particular one that still makes you
think like damn I cannot believe we were
actually able to pull that off oh my God
the whole movie I feel that way I look
back now we shot the whole thing in 18
days we did a couple of days of
additional shooting but I looked back
myself and we saw the first schedule
come from rid we turned to each and said
this is impossible this is impossible we
can't shoot this movie in this time
allotted I remember Jason was just you
know being Jason a great producer he was
he's like you could do it you could do
it just kept saying you could do it and
we did it somehow we did it but
whenever you get into action I think
that's where horror is one thing you
know doing a scare or something you can
create a mood and but when you do action
you have to get some coverage to it for
the most part and just the time
restraints on the early Blum House homes
like they got better in the franchise
grew but God it was very hard so I
didn't think any of it was possible the
the pool table scene is still one of my
one of my favorite fight scenes ever
that's great and yeah the stunned people
were amaz we cast all stunt people to
play the the bad guys the kids coming in
and they were just truly amazing yeah so
that we shot to giving like that's the
kind of scene we had to shoot it in four
hours so we looked on paper and we're
like that's impossible how are we doing
this so we had the most amazing stunt
team we pre-vised it which was very
important which was you know shooting
some version of it on you know cheaply
without iPhones beforehand so we knew
everything we were doing so you know
pre-production becomes key in these
things as you know more than anybody
um so yeah that's I'm gonna have you
bring that scene up I forgot that that
was almost impossible we did it again
somehow we pulled it off and listen as
the filmmaker I still feel like we
missed 100 shots but I think it tells
the story appropriately so but I look
back on it I'm like I can't look at it
I'm like oh we missed this we missed
this here and this angle and this lens
so it's a anyway four hours is blowing
my mind right now wow yeah could you
imagine and we did it even on
on Anarchy we were doing stuff we were
out and about on the streets of LA night
shooting like six to six six at night
six in the morning and
big action scenes we were doing in half
a day I still look back I'm like and I
think we all kind of went mad because it
was so intense and night shoots 30 days
of nights uh we were slowly going like
we were all getting in that weird Purge
mindset so well very hard though night
shoots we'll do that for you
so speaking of your your purgers in the
first movie one thing I've always
wondered about did you ever come up with
any sort of backstory for Reese
wakefield's character just you know I
get the vibe that because of his uh
because of his wardrobe maybe he's a
college student but even just you know
what put him on this path in life that
he is someone who wholeheartedly
Embraces the purge like this no it's a
great question I do character studies
for every character personal things I
try you know see how much we need in the
script but for me I need to know where
everybody comes from so you nailed it he
was a college kid I think for me The
Purge was passed down generationally
from the parents buying into a certain
government propaganda here especially
the rich since this is kind of a caste
system Rich versus poor and the
elimination elimination of the
disenfranchised and Society ID
ultimately becomes the big metaphor from
for The Purge so that the government
doesn't have to economically take care
of them so we always thought yes college
kid frat boy
ing into the propaganda probably from
Daddy who owns some big Corporation
Works on Wall Street or something like
that uh yeah so I went out getting
deeply into that but it was it was that
you nailed it I think his and when we
found that Crest on his jacket it kind
of told that without having again it's
better to show it than say it so the
crest like you picked up on there's a
boy of privilege this is a boy of wealth
buying it to Daddy's propaganda and the
mommy's propaganda government propaganda
so yeah that was you nailed it that was
the backstory pretty much then my next
follow-up question to that this is kind
of a big convoluted idea but why why do
you think James got involved in The
Purge the way he did versus purging like
Reese wakefield's character does and
then how does that impact his kids that
younger generation where they're more
open-minded to understanding why like
The Purge The Purge is bad and shouldn't
be happening whereas that that middle
generation so to speak in this situation
he is very much going down that bad path
it's a great great way to look I was
always looking at it like gun gun laws
or gun lack of gun control laws or what
people feel about especially in America
Society about guns in general you have
people who own guns who advocate for
guns that everybody needs a gun and then
I know people who don't have guns but
believe in first in the right to own you
know arms so I always thought James fell
into
I don't Purge myself yet the government
has told me that this works for society
there is less crime in society now so
he's bought into it but he doesn't have
maybe he even deep thinks deep down that
he doesn't have the courage to purge but
the conceit of purging and now that he's
economically
prosperous because of power generally
selling security systems
um but that does allow the fact that he
does encourage and he's not this
wholehearted steadfast like one must
Purge to be a better Society but he
believes in more general terms I think
opens up the opportunity as you ask
which is a great question for his
children to have different views on it
yeah I love that
yeah I think that's I'm happy you
brought up and picked up on it so I
think when you you know the new
generation I even see it now I see some
people even with climate my new movie
The metaphors climate change the one I
do with Pete Davidson but you see the
different generational views on climate
change I know old people don't believe
it's happening at all and then as we get
younger we hear more about it we learn
about it so I was generationally I think
views are more open to the youth I think
people uh and I think the kids represent
especially the max Burke old character
was very yeah well bringing him up
here's another thing I've been I've been
wondering because the surviving sandens
do not return in the franchise what do
you think the future holds for the three
of them how did that Purge Night
experience kind of put them maybe on a
different path than they were prior
absolutely I think yeah I was I always
wanted to follow them up and listen if
everything if the strike ends and we get
a chance there is talk of doing a kind
of an interesting take on a TV show
where I would be able to do that because
we'd be able to explore very intimate
Purge stories but I don't know that's
true I hope um
I think they move away I would say they
would do what I did I think a family
that experiences that much trauma and
loss on that night and Lena's character
I always thought was way more than James
um the Lena Headey character was
questioning the purge deep in a way that
he wasn't he was just accepting the
financial
the financial rewards of selling
security systems and she was more like
Lena always said she wanted to play like
she was dead inside that The Purge the
mere fact that the purge existed had
killed her soul so she kind of wanted to
play it I think she plays it beautifully
she's constantly kind of looking at her
Reflections and contemplating quietly
what this all means so I think I think
if you experience that level of trauma
you exit pretty quickly the country I
don't think you can buy into a
government system that uh sanctions this
so I think that I always wanted to
follow the sentence on that journey to
another country which I thought would be
but then that country you know maybe
starts supporting too and things the
cycle of crap continues in the in the
world I do have many a worldwide
question about uh how The Purge changes
everything everywhere but going back to
the house idea this is another thing
that I've thought too much about like
doesn't The Purge cause major like a
major housing crisis like every single
person that experiences the horrors of
The Purge in their own home and survives
don't they then want to get rid of that
home and is that home harder to sell
well because murder happened in it it
either makes it in this crazy world I
was thinking the same thing like what
would happen to the homes when murder
happened would that become a benefit
purging happened here this is a house
that has supported the purge so you get
your hardcore believers who think that
well that's a house that's a patriotic
home it supported the system or it's the
opposite you get more like an
open-minded person who's anti-purge
would find that to be the most grotesque
home in the world
whereas you know I grew up I was
obsessed with the Manson Murders as a
child not in a good way I just was so
terrified of them
um and I really became obsessed where I
really studied them and whatnot I used
to drive by the homes in La whenever I
would visit
but I did I met people in those Journeys
who were driving by the homes because
they wanted to buy the homes now I could
never live in one of the homes where the
low Bianca or the tape murders occurred
but there were people who thought it
would have been very cool and
interesting and the ghosts of the past
might be inhabiting the space so you
always have the two ends of the spectrum
on uh on housing markets and what it all
means but I it could go the other way
where a house that has purging would be
uh
you know a big sale in the marketplace
maybe I could see I could see both being
a possibility absolutely absolutely yeah
all right I warned you this up top I've
got some very very specific questions
from someone who's watched these movies
too much I hope I can I hope I can
explain all this properly I have a
timeline question for you so
the sixth Purge it happens in 2023 I
believe that's the one that happens in
Anarchy so that would make the first
official Nationwide Purge in 2018 right
in the first movie I believe there's
footage of purging happening in both
2018 and 2017 and 2017's footage is in
Staten Island so if if the first Purge
the experiment happened in 2016 what
happened in 2017 was that a nationwide
experiment before the event officially
kicked off I think I think you're right
I think listen to timeline's such a
disaster because we had a lot we
couldn't go back and retroactively open
up Purge one to change the dates when I
realized oh I'm old Wolfie I can't make
this work so so yes you're right I
always believe that the second Purge
wouldn't would go they went from Staten
Island which was a borrow a small
Borough seven miles wide I think they
would go to a state Purge so they'd pick
a state New York Georgia I think the
footage might be in New York now that
you said yeah so I think they would go
then they and so they keep expanding it
to see if they can keep selling the idea
as they would at any kind of product
right so it's the expansion I think
but that doesn't fit like I'm the first
to admit the timeline's a disaster I
mean really it's not that much of a
disaster a lot of it makes a lot of
sense and does connect I think that's
anyway because when we did the TV show I
remember sitting in the writer's room
and we were trying to work out the time
when I'm like oh damn it I think we're
off we're all trying to fix it and
saying Okay blah blah blah but you
picked it up yes that's that's the issue
that's what future movies are for though
exactly exactly I'm gonna jump ahead to
the forever Purge now because I know you
initially wrote that script to be an end
for the entire franchise so at the time
why did you feel that particular story
was the right place to end the entire
series and then ultimately you know what
changed and what is it about this idea
for a sixth film that suggests that we
need more Purge stories or or maybe not
even your idea for the sixth film maybe
even the state of the country right now
that says you need more Purge movies
that's so it's weird but you bring it up
I always say to Universal like you ready
to do another one I'm like well
I'm not I don't know I don't know yeah I
always say I don't know until an idea
you know just comes to me and I think
what's fueled all the ideas is the the
social Discord in the country right now
the changing
political landscape has fueled me I have
very strong views I think that uh the
audience is picking up on especially in
four and five what My Views are I
receive a lot of hate mail from one of
the political parties they kind of see
what I'm saying I think it's my
political stance has become quite clear
I think um
which has caused some you know backlash
from both studio and the the audience
but it is definitely definitely what you
said it's the it's the political
landscape that that makes me keep
wanting to purge and I was done on five
I thought it was a cool way to end it
where America was burning and people
were treating to Mexico as this Refuge
this escape from American System I was
completely broken
and then I literally woke up one day
with an idea I remember calling
Sebastian I picture to him he's like God
damn it we're back purging he did not he
was not he was like he loved it but he's
like oh I didn't I thought we were done
I pictured the universe Jason and
Universal they loved it so I wrote six
based on my thoughts on what's going on
in the country and how can I extrapolate
that in the purge metaphor and what it
means to be an American at this point so
I'm psyched about sex I think the budget
I think I could be honest here the
budget was quite large very large and I
think Universal the pandemic made them
rethink some of the franchises on how we
proceed so I think they're still
contemplating like what what is the
proper way to do the next Purge film so
we're kind of in this limbo State
especially with the writer strike now
too well yeah that too yeah so but yeah
Purge six is just it's my way of looking
at the country now I think you know I
grew up watching Logan's Run and Soylent
Green and the Mad Mag and John Carpenter
and George Romero who's
the socio-political
messaging was within the films they were
smuggling ideas into the film and
so for me I was just kind of for six I
was extrapolating on the Discord and
taking it to its furthest
where as far as you can take that idea
of um what's going on I feel in the
country and the political landscape and
it's a broken America we're remapping
six is about the remapping of America
based on ideology sexuality sexuality
and religion so that the states have
broken down you have your you have your
black State you have your gay state so
you have your white Evangelical State
and it's really a broken country and
what's so strange is that Madre Taylor
green
I'm not going to say more than her name
there
um recently wished for an America like
that which to me would be the most
nightmarish version it goes against
everything that America stands for
um I grew up in New York so it's you
know the cliche The Melting Pot is true
and that's how I'd like to see our
country represented by many faces and
different religions and sexualities she
doesn't see it that way so there's part
of the body politic that doesn't want
that and that's what purge six is it is
this kind of broken America
um down in this remapping and then they
take pictures one state that purges
still so that's where it takes place
anyway so if I don't know if I babbled
on that one no I mean it's It's Curious
information and I think it might answer
another question I had about uh about
Purge six and it's does it take place
after the events of forever approach
where we have a broken American I'm
going to assume by that answer that that
is the case it does it's it's I think
it's 50 I think I say 15 I'm not great
at timelines as you but I think I say
it's 15 years after the events of purge
five so we're really broken and we've
and then we pick up the
we pick up the Leo character he's our
lead again from Purge two and three yeah
I always love uh I love a Purge movie
with Frank but like literally any thing
he touches signed me up and his
enthusiasm for everything he does I find
to be quite infectious oh that's great
he's the best to work with no one's
there for the process more I could walk
into every movie with Frank so I love
hearing that
here's a question you might not be able
to answer especially with your approach
to coming up with ideas for new Purge
movies but
I mean do you ever Envision a scenario
where the purge franchise wraps up on a
positive note absolutely it's so weird
you bring that up as so you know one
this is going to sound strange it's like
backwards motivation but one of the
reasons
I always said I if I have a story I'll
tell it I'll tell Universal but also
Sebastian and I very quite very aware
that in the wrong hands we always felt
the purge can turn into
very exploitative
could turn into some kind of torture
porn or without any political messaging
or so what and and in designing each of
the films I think I did this
subconsciously first and then it started
we started seeing the pattern of what I
was doing was we tried to end the films
in this incredibly nihilistic concept
with someone saving someone's life so we
always show you okay let's end this
even though this is the darkest possible
scenario
let's end with people like even part one
ends with the saving of the stranger uh
I think two ends with saving not only
the father who killed Leo's child in the
drunk driving accident it ends with
saving Leo by the two female leads three
ends with saving a very bad man they
don't kill the senator who's running for
president and they um you know the
preacher should say they save as they
they decide not to kill so there's
always a decision not to kill or to save
but you're right I would and we tried to
do with three where three I thought was
the original ending just do a Trilogy
get out where uh the Elizabeth Mitchell
character you know she becomes president
she gets rid of The Purge and we're now
in a hopeful America where the purge is
no longer and obviously we reverse that
and she was kicked you know voted out of
office and The Purge was reinstated but
I like you're right I like that you pick
I don't know if you picked enough
subconsciously but we were trying to
infuse some hope
and this incredibly nihilistic concept
thread that I I hold tight to when I can
find and I mean and I an idea like this
or a question like this is is also near
impossible to answer it's a very big
question too but I I think about it a
lot with with the purge and then you
know we also have something like the
handmaid's tale where you know they're
cautionary tales people seem to watch
these things and say that is horrific I
can't imagine that ever happening but
with both stories and even with how uh
how films and shows tackle AI nowadays
it seems like all we're doing is
creeping closer to those horrific
realities that are being shown on screen
and I don't I don't quite understand why
and I don't understand what else movies
and shows could be doing to maybe help
that not happen right no you're
absolutely my producer actually says
that all the time because you keep
predicting these terrible outcomes in
America like Purge five people thought
when we screamed that they thought we
shot it after January 6th because it was
so reminiscent of the day we shot it a
year before that we were just holding it
for covid and um so he's like can you
just write something positive maybe
something positive will come of what you
uh so I made a small film in between my
uh between Purge the purging and my
newest film I made a small that I always
felt was the anti-purge it was about how
movies could Inspire us to do things
yeah this is the night about Rocky III
and so I'm always saying okay we and I
think my new one I don't want to give
away the ending but I hope this I think
there's some hope infused within it but
I think you're right it's like how can
we
these dystopian Tales kind of end so
realistically what no hope or just
constant dread but I've tried to fight
that a little bit with some even in six
I think it ends with some hope in a
maybe a more uh
positive path that we can all go on as a
country
yeah that would be a beautiful thing be
a miracle at this point I would love I'd
be holding tight to that that little bit
of hope uh when we get it
um before I do have a question or two
about the home but before I get there I
wanted to Circle back to the potential
TV show that could come out of this you
already mentioned that it was uh that it
could be an opportunity to explore more
intimate stories is that also an
opportunity I might have misheard before
but is that also an opportunity to
potentially bring in the surviving
sandens or would it Focus okay that's
what I was thinking about I think it
would be a great way I can't give away
the conceit but it opens up it opens it
up in a way the canvas would be we can
pay attention to a lot of people
but even the movies always have to be as
you know the summer release is July 4th
they have this have this kind of
momentum like a punch in the face
so the nuances I always say I'm not the
most nuanced filmmaker in The Purge
world because we kind of just really
slamming both the messaging and the
you know the the story points home
in that 95 minutes we have I think
indeed the beauty of TV what I'm
learning because I'm a morph I'm
definitely more of a film guy but what
I'm learning about TV and watching TV
and learning more about it is uh the
real estate just allows you to dive
deeper into things that you can never do
in a movie take your time really explain
why someone would pick up a gun on that
night what drives them to this decision
in a way that I really can't do in the
film
um so I think it would be great we can
get in and we can get into more detailed
things of what happened to the sandon
family uh even other characters
throughout the people that fall in love
with we can get into that I think I
think the conceit of the show if it
happens will allow entry into smaller
films and the revisiting characters too
I will say when it happens because I am
hopeful that all of this all of this
stuff will work out in a way that favors
what people should have been getting all
along and then we will get many more
Purge movies and TV shows I like to
speak things into existence
but you uh you do have uh one movie in
the can the one you worked on with uh
Pete Davidson the home so because of how
the purge came to be I was wondering
what in particular inspired that story
idea was it another personal thing you
were experiencing that you wanted to
explore via film yeah it was uh so I
wrote that with a buddy actually a local
cop who was my best friend uh we were
sitting during covid in my backyard it's
his family and my family weren't as we
used to call the bubble his uh his two
boys played with my daughter a lot in
the backyard so it was the only other
family we saw and we would just extract
we were talking about
and we're not saying too much I don't
want to give away my metaphors and my
pretentious part of my writing process
because I think it exists unto itself as
a genre a psychological horror film I
think in the you know one of my favorite
films is Rosemary's Baby that's
Rosemary's Baby kind of film without the
devil worship
um
but there was uh I wanted to explore in
the horror genre because I think horror
sci-fi and action are great ways to
metaphorically explore without
proselytizing although I think in The
Purge I started the proselytize a little
bit in four and five
um but I think I don't think an audience
wants to feel that preached too so I
think
you know Scorsese years ago spoke about
something called Smuggler Cinema in the
40s and 50s the directors who were on
the contract with the studios were
getting very sick of making cowboy
movies and War movies so they started
smuggling some socio-political
commentary into the films in a very
subtle way so the studios wouldn't get
mad at them but I always thought that
was an incredibly cool concept and we
saw that with George you know George
Romero and my favorite film one of my
filmmakers John Carpenter just start
smuggling these ideas in we did it with
the purge so the idea of working I was
trying to like how do I work climate
change and global warming into a kind of
metaphorical horror exercise and we came
up with this crazy idea I think it's
crazy
um my buddy and I that we feel somewhat
of a metaphor for this crazy time we're
in with global warming and and I think
we'll see people see it that's you know
you know sometimes you do these things
and you want to people and I'll say this
during the test screenings a good
portion of the audience saw the
messaging also the thematics underneath
the the horror the genre elements so uh
yeah I'm kind of I'm talking very
abstractly without giving it away I
should stop the abstract talk I know can
become boring I'll dare I'll dare to ask
one more question about Rory so you're
bringing up the the environmental aspect
of it and then it also involves a
nursing home well that's the thing yes
so that's why it's a very it's much more
I think much more subtle than the uh
purges messaging in that yes it takes
place where so you're dealing with Pete
Davidson playing a very dramatic role I
think that's what's kind of cool for
people to see it's not uh it's not the
Pete we've become accustomed to it all
and he's wonderful he's a wonderful
dramatic actor which was even surprising
to me on set I would say how did you
learn to do this Pete quite often but he
just has this Natural Instinct and he
went with it and he did not rely on the
comedy at all because there's none in
the movie so
so not to give to again too much away
but it's about him he's a graffiti
artist he gets in trouble with the law
and his community service instead of
doing jail time is that uh he has to
live and become the new super at a
retirement old age home so it's about
you know older Generations dealing with
the youth youth in America and obviously
then it kicks into heavy horror and some
crazy uh you know mythology about what
these people are and who they are and
what they're doing in this home and how
that affects the Youth of America so I
think the metaphor is there for people
who I always think that's what's I think
in this Smuggler Cinema Realm
again you don't want to hit people with
a hammer so the people who want to see
the messaging or the thematics
the sub thematics I think it'll be there
for them to say oh I see what is being
said about global warming but for other
people they'll just be like I don't care
about that at all I just want to watch a
horror movie so you have thoroughly
piqued my interest so I'm not gonna
bother you with any more story questions
but one more question about it just in
terms in terms of the timeline here when
can we expect to see it do you have any
ballpark I literally no joke finished it
yes yes the Final Mix was uh was finally
done it took a little extra because we
had to wait we did one additional Day
shooting and Pete's TV show bupkis we
had to wait about four months because
because of a hair continuity problem we
were dealing with so we had to wait for
him to finish before we could do that so
that slowed things down so but we
finally finished which is great uh I
feel great about it I don't know so I'm
a first time I'm working with um Miramax
is a financier not a distributor so I
have to sell it so I'm gonna wait on
Bill block was wonderful the head of
Miramax he's gonna now I think I hand it
off to him and see so I can't this is
such a new world to me the sale the
selling of a film like this that uh I
don't know if it takes a week or a year
I have literally no idea so as soon as I
find something out I'll shoot you a text
I'll tell you what's going on I like the
sound of that I eagerly await that text
I will send lots of good vibes your way
for that movie
Purge franchise and in the meantime I
will continue watching and re-watching
the movies and the show we already have
James thank you so much for your time
today thank you you're the best thank
you congrats on everything thank you